Por qué una delegación africana Presenta
una propuesta de paz para el conflicto
en Ucrania qué tan afectada se ve África
con esta guerra
África está muy afectada por esta guerra
por el suministro de granos que ayuda
mucho a la como combatir el hombre en
África y los precios que están
incrementando a nivel internacional pero
si uno mira bien lo que está pasando en
el mundo de una vez que aplica Sudáfrica
y los países africanos los seis que
están pensando con una iniciativa de eso
de una vez antes acusan al África de
poder armas a Rusia lo mismo que
hicieron con China antes mismo de que
china hizo su propuesta de paz África
está muy golpeado por supuesto por esta
guerra ellos quieren que esa guerra
termine lo antes posible
de alguna manera que la propuesta se
anuncie desde Rusia le quita legitimidad
Es decir podría considerarse como una
estrategia formulada por Rusia donde
primen sus intereses para acabar la
guerra
la guerra no creo porque el presidente
La mafiosa hablo con los dos líderes
antes mismo de emprender la misión de
paz o sea hablo con selensky y habló con
el presidente vladimido el mismo lo
anunció Entonces si él habla con los dos
y los dos aceptan para recibirlo
entonces No podemos de una vez sesgar de
que eso va a aparecer como si fuera una
cosa que va a estar en pro de Rusia
bueno la delegación africana fue a Moscú
qué relaciones tienen países como uganda
con Ucrania Es decir para poder avanzar
en una negociación
por supuesto no es tanto la relación
pero
los los las votaciones en la ONU esos
seis países que están en esta misión
ellos seis Normalmente se abstienen en
las votaciones entonces la relación que
anda puede tener es terminar con la
guerra para que no se sientan porque
están muy afectados sobre todo esos
países en cuestiones del hombre del
control de población de de situación
interno de esos países por eso están muy
pero muy
interesado en que eso se resuelve lo
antes posible y qué tan importante sería
el papel de una delegación africana qué
tanto peso tendría por ejemplo al
compararlo con el de China o Turquía
entonces Sudáfrica puede fácilmente
persuadir a China a que haga presión
sobre Rusia para que accede a parar la
guerra Sudáfrica también puede acceder a
China para ejercer presión sobre
una playa para acceder a una negociación
de conflicto entonces la delegación
africana si uno mira todos los países
están tratando de convencer a los
africanos para tomar partido entonces la
delegación africana es muy importante en
formular un plan de paz donde los dos
partidos los dos beligerantes pueden
aceptarlo Porque esos países han votado
se han abstenido en votar en las
votaciones de Naciones Unidas cuando se
tratan de esos dos países